GRIFF: REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS
SENDING MORE MIGRANTS TO
DEMOCRATIC STRONGHOLDS AS MORE
MIGRANTS AND DRUGS FLOW OVER OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
JOINING US FROM TEXAS, FORMER
ACTING ICE DIRECTOR TOM HOMAN,
TOM, THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU A SHORT
INTERVIEW I DID WITH A
VENEZUELAN MIGRANT NAMED KHAN
THAT WAS ON THE BUS THAT TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT SENT
SPECIFICALLY TO VICE PRESIDENT
HARRY'S HOME IN RESPONSE TO HER
COMMENTS ON LAST SUNDAY'S MEET
THE PRESS WHERE SHE SAID THE
BORDER WAS SECURE.
HERE IS WHAT THE MIGRANT FROM
VENEZUELA TOLD ME, TAKE A
LISTEN.
>> IT'S OPEN, NOT CLOSE.
THE BORDER IS OPEN.
IT'S OPEN BECAUSE WE ENTER, WE
COME IN FREE.
NO PROBLEM.
YEAH, WE CAME ILLEGALLY, NOT
LEGAL.
GRIFF: TOM, YOUR REACTION?
TOM: I SAW THE INTERVIEW LIVE
AND I SAID AT THE TIME THAT
KAMALA HARRIS, THE SUPPOSED
TSAR, 150 YARDS AWAY IN HER
RESIDENCE AND SHE'S LOOKING FOR
THE ROOT CAUSES OF THIS MASSIVE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, SHE CAN
WALK WHERE YOU WERE, GRIFF, AND
ASK THE SAME QUESTION AND SHE
WOULD COME OUT BECAUSE THE
BORDER IS OPEN, THEY CROSS
EASILY AND THEY'VE BEEN INVITED,
SO THERE YOU GO.
OF COURSE, SHE'S IGNORING IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GREAT
QUESTION AND I THOUGHT THE
PERSON THAT YOU TALKED WAS
HONEST.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT IS A GENIUS.
BUT WHAT HE'S DONE IS GETTING
THESE DEMOCRATIC MAYORS AND VICE
PRESIDENT UP IN ARMS, MORE
PEOPLE, MORE NETWORKS ARE
TALKING ABOUT SO HE CREATED A
NATIONAL CONVERSATION THAT WILL
KEEP THIS ISSUE ON THE FRONT
PAGES.
GRIFF: WHO KNEW AND YOU'RE RIGHT
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS, I'VE TRAVELED TO THE
PANAMANIAN JUNGLE, MOST
DANGEROUS ON THE PLANET, I
TRAVELED 7,000 MILES WITH
MULTIPLE CARAVANS FROM HONDURAS,
TO GUATEMALA THROUGH THE
ENTIRETY OF MEXICO TO PLACES
LIKE EAGLE PASS, WHO KNEW IT
ONLY TOOK A COUPLE OF BUSES TO
VICE PRESIDENT'S HARRIS HOUSE
AND A PLANE TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
TO GET THE COUNTRY TO START
TALKING ABOUT IT.
NOW LET ME JUST SHARE OUR
VIEWERS A LITTLE COMPARISON
BECAUSE I WANT YOU TO SHOW THIS.
IF YOU COMPARE MARTHA'S VINEYARD
TO DEL RIO AND THIS IS ACTUALLY
THE NUMBER OF ENCOUNTERS, NEARLY
50,000 IN DEL RIO WHO HAS A
POPULATION OF JUST UNDER 35,000.
THAT'S JUST IN THE MONTH OF JULY
AND YET MARTHA'S VINEYARD,
POPULATION OF 17,000 HAD 50
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE MANY MARTHA'S
VINEYARD IS FREAKING OUT AND
HERE IS A WOMAN WHO WAS TRYING
TO HELP.
HERE IS WHAT SHE SAID.
>> AT SOME POINT IN TIME THEY
WILL HAVE TO MOVE SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
WE CANNOT -- WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SERVICES TO TAKE CARE OF 50
IMMIGRANTS AND WE CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE HOUSING, WE ARE IN A
HOUSING CRISIS.
GRIFF: A CRISIS, TOM.
TOM: SHE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT THE
CRISIS IS.
IF SHE WANTS TO SEE A CRISIS,
SHE NEEDS TO GO TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THE MAYOR OF CHICAGO SAID IT WAS
RACIST, OTHER PEOPLE SAY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
SEVERAL SAID THIS IS HATE, IT IS
INHUMANE, IF THEY WANT TO SEE
INHUMANE CONDITIONS, GO DOWN TO
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
OVER 1300 DEAD MIGRANTS DIED ON
U.S. SOIL SINCE JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT.
WELL OVER A HUNDRED AMERICANS
DYING OF FENTANYL OVERDOSES
SINCE JOE BIDEN BECAME
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE 31% OF WOMEN
MAKING THE JOURNEY GET SEXUAL
ASSAULTED AND CHILDREN ARE
DROWNING IN THE RIVER, IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT INHUMANITY GO
TO THE BORDER.
THOSE MEMBERS I SAY WELCOME TO
THE CRISIS, EVERY STATE IS A
BORDER STATE NOW AND WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE FENTANYL
THAT'S MAKING EVERY, TOWN, CITY
AND STATE BECAUSE OF THE OPEN
BORDER.
FINALLY THEY ARE SPEAKING UP AND
MAYBE THEY WILL CARE.
IF THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, CARE ABOUT THE
FENTANYL OVERDOSES AND OPEN
BORDER THAT WILL ATTRACT KNOWN
AND SUSPECTED TERRORISTS.
MAYBE YOU WILL START CARING IF
YOU SEE IT ON YOUR FRONT DOOR.
GRIFF: CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM WANTS GOVERNORS
ABBOTT AND DESANTIS CHARGED WITH
KIDNAPPING.
TOM: LET'S OPEN THE CAN OF WORMS
GOVERNOR NEWSOM.
YOU HAVE A SANCTUARY STATE.
YOU CAN SEAL AND HARBOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THAT'S A FELONY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE INDUCEMENT
AND ENCOURAGEMENT OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
WHEN YOU PROMISE FREE HEALTH
CARE AND DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU
PROMISE YOU DON'T WORK WITH ICE
AND YOU ICE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
JAILS AND CRIMINAL ALIENS BE
RELEASED BACK INTO THE STREET,
IS THAT NOT INDUCING AND
ENCOURAGING ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
I THINK YOU WILL FIND YOURSELF
IN TROUBLE YOURSELF SO IF YOU
WANT TO OPEN THE CAN OF WORMS,
LET'S GO.
GRIFF: FORMER ACTING ICE
DIRECTOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR